the Joe Rogan experience one of the
things that disturbed me greatly today
is there is a movement and I don't know
how big it is but it's a movement for
people to try to recognize pedophiles as
a sexual distinction a sexual
designation rather than a sick disease
that similar to being trans or being
right or that some people are just born
pedophiles well I think what's important
there is it's not just a crime because a
crime can be fixed and treated and so I
think it is important to understand
these people will always psychologically
be pedophiles and you're not going to
get them to be like
straight you know homo no therapy that's
ever been shown that I think it's like
trying to make someone who's gay it's
straight is it really that so that's my
understanding if that's the case and is
there an argument that we should be more
compassionate with them as long as they
don't act on that but that's the danger
because the other thing what they don't
understand is from their point of view
those kids are giving consent which they
are right the kids saying yes so they're
like look maybe that's what's scary and
even know if they do right nobody they
they don't think a statutory rape being
a thing and I knew okay this this way I
interned in a place long ago and there
was a librarian who worked there like a
Guido type you know and girl or guy guy
and years later he was arrested he was a
schoolteacher he was arrested in an
undercover sting trying to meet a kid
who he knew was 13 or 12 in a park to
try to sleep with him right this was a
Jeanine Pirro who later became a fox
commentator he got out of jail and I see
him on Facebook he's married with kids
and it's just like I you think it's fine
that that's just scary [ __ ] and it's
another thing to be switched gender too
if you're going for young boys you're
gonna go to like regular aged women I
don't see how that would work right
right and this is something that's such
a taboo topic that I don't think once
you for a lot of people correctly once
you start talking about kids and
sexuality their hackles raised it is a
PC subject cause it's like while you've
been introducing this into the Commerce
where you going with this it's a very
very very slippery slope well if you're
trying to say if they're trying to say
that this is something that people are
born with I don't think there's evidence
that people just are born that way
I think there's evidence that people
become that way from sexual abuse
yes that's true too absolutely and they
think it's improper never heard of
anybody they grew up in a normal
household wasn't abused is that the case
I'm not in a position to talk about this
at all I think we have probably have
very few cases of pedophiles on the
record explaining how they came to this
point of view right but in either
situation born or abused I can't see how
this is something that's going to be an
emotion level you're gonna be able to
turn them away well it's also a super
the idea of that being in your
neighborhood yes this is in your
neighborhood you've got this guy who
likes to [ __ ] kids and he promises not
to do it anymore they did a few times
they locked him up in a cage now you
live down the street and he locked up in
a cage where he was traumatized also
further traumatize oh yeah so and also
if he promises not to do it but knowing
when he's looking at she's checking out
my son or my daughter yeah mmm I did not
expect to be talking about this today
I'm now course